الى تطورات المواجهات في السودان حيث
تجددت الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
بالتزامن مع تحليق طائرات حربيه جنوبيه
العاصمه الخرطوم حول هذه التطورات ينضم
الينا من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره الطاهر
المرضي اذا كما يبدو خلفك سحب الدخان
ترتفع دليل على استمرار هذا الاقتتال
نعم اليوم كان الاقتتال عنيف كما كان
بالامس حول هذه المنطقه في جنوب الخرطوم
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
هذه المنطقه تعتبر منطقه حساسه هي يعني
تضم مصنع
اليرموك
للاسلحه وكذلك تضم اكبر مجموعه للمستودعات
الغاز وغيرها من الوقود اشتعلت النيران في
هذه المنطقه كما تشاهدون خلفي كانت هذه
السنه الدخان نتيجه لهذه المعارك الضاريه
التي استخدمت فيها جميع الاسلحه الاسلحه
الثقيله والاسلحه الخفيفه وكذلك الطيران
في هذه المنطقه تحديدا كانت المواجهات
عنيفه في منطقه ايضا في منطقه جبرا
وبالقرب من شارع الهوى اللي هو يقع جنوب
يقع شمال للمستودع الرئيسيه في هذه
المنطقه حتى الان المعارك لا تزال مستمره
وهنالك
تصريحات كانت بالامس
للجيش السوداني قال ان قوات الدعم السريع
حاولت الهجوم او اقتحام منطقه
اليرموك ولكنه قال قام بتصديها ثم تجدد
الاشتباك مره اخرى اليوم وكان عنيفا هذا
الوضع يشابهه ايضا وضع ايضا قصف عنيف في
شرق النيل هناك ايضا الجيش السوداني قام
باستخدام المدفعيه ضد مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع وهنالك ايضا
سمعنا دويا في جراد في مدينه ام درمان هذا
هو واقع الحال وهذه هي مؤشرات الحرب في
تصاعد خاصه اليوم في جنوب الخرطوم هذه
الحربه ايضا امتدت الى اقليم دارفور حيث
كانت هنالك اشتباكات
في داخل مدينه الجنينه هذه المدينه التي
تعاني اصلا اوضاعا ماساويه خاصه فيما يختص
بالاوضاع الماساويه والظروف التي تعيشها
هناك في مدينه الجنينه حيث نهار النظام
الصحي
والنظام الصحي وكذلك الكهرباء والمياه
وخرجت منها المنظمات الانسانيه والتصاعدت
فقط منها المناشدات هناك في هذه المدينه
للمنظمات الانسانيه لمساعده المحتاجين
المساعدات التي تنادي بها دارفور كذلك لم
تصل الخرطوم
لسبب بسبب عدم تطبيق اتفاق جده لفتح
المسارات ومحاوله تعزيز الموقف الصحي الذي
خرجت عدد كبير من المستشفيات وان
المستشفيات التي تعمل تعمل باقل من
امكانياتها تنقصها ايضا المعينات الطبيه
الكل الان يعني ينتظر وقلق ينتظر اذا ما
افلحت الجهود
افلحت الجهود في محاوله لاعاده طرفي
الصراع الى طاوله الطاهر المرضي حدثنا من
الخرطوم